all right here's a little flunk my aunt
boys pull my nuts [ __ ]
sorry sorry what that in a cart earlier
I'm just a little bit high-strung today
because I'm on some pain medication from
this head surgery this is Aunt Lucy cat
Arel Oh Lucy fur is a beautiful
beautiful jig like a beautiful reptile
she's a bad around her neck oh she's a
bad that's the least of her [ __ ]
words about look at her [ __ ] teeth
bro
I think she looks nice and I like where
your head that I like I like I like this
positive feel right now she clearly
stapled her eyebrows that's cool that's
cool better that's brave didn't imagine
going to bed at night instead of just
closing your eyes stapling them shut
that's like I'm getting sleep no matter
what anybody else wants yeah imagine
feeling your way to the kitchen in the
morning to make a [ __ ] a - gorilla
egg or to eat flies imagine you can't
find your staple remover and you have to
[ __ ] drive to work with your eyes
state I think that's what she wants bro
yeah imagine waking up thinking her
[ __ ] a lizard dude
Oh imagine laying on the road after
rains in the Sun and enjoying it Oh
imagine laying on the rocks like an
iguana ha beautiful ah dude
now we're talking about it belly up baby
Oh get them raise you to God that's
somebody danton huh yep she graduated
from University of Wisconsin I don't
believe that and she did this herself
the horns are all clay this is all clay
oh she's a makeup person I think yes she
did this the tats are real though that's
a real is the she for real - I think
maybe I don't have an idea artist she
was gonna have to do this stuff is there
any other facts on so she went to unity
with Scott Wisconsin lie I'm assuming
she go Badgers baby ain't no right now
don't jump on the train dude well yeah
they get the [ __ ] running back
they're badgers bro I know that's like
your teens I'll shoe bro I know but just
on the Badger train imagine being a
badger and doing something they're
always good dude no he's pretty solid
they're deep or fed white boys great
running back that's what they do that's
true but this year they've taken it to
another level scored a few more points
than usual and I'll see what's up
pac-12 sucks monkey nut so okay what do
they want to know about this lady they
just want to do this floor somebody
she's only cool in October you feel me
like this isn't she's not coming to the
holiday parties besides Halloween right
that's a thing definitely she doesn't
seem like that Christmas Eve kind of bad
girl like if I if I she seems nice but
if I saw her under the mistletoe dude I
would shoot that thing yes so go bro
that's what I would do like quadri is
mayo broad [ __ ] be out that [ __ ] I'd
be like his brother Rock and shoot this
[ __ ] right the tail let those sharp
teeth dude imagine you can't find out
you got to open envelope some mail or
something you can't find something your
lady's right there to help you I'm
pretty pretty handy you know imagine you
want to get in what can I saw of a buna
of a pea or beanie weenie dude don't eat
tuna man this is dangerous it has lead
poisoning to my buddy
mercury do my buddy Billy Richie ate
some led braids like 19 cans of tuna in
a row dude and once you were Mercury's
going do you it's like you're on a shift
like on a scary ship all the time
started rocking back and forth bro for a
while and he's better now shoutout be
our brothers there might be some mental
health racial line gang brothers do
could walk across a park Dam by himself
dude pretty cool you like this ant
though good luck what are you talking
about good luck dude
I mean just in life dude if you pretty
one for 10 years tatted up lizard give
me a tough road for you oh she looked
honestly she's beautiful for one
beautiful song that dude you keep saying
that yeah because I mean it but she also
looks like an aquarium [ __ ] a bowl of
Fruity Pebbles so I think there's kind
of a mixed bag going on here what I
can't what the part that gets me is the
batter
the bad that's the least of my [ __ ]
really no more way she's gonna see the
show and put a [ __ ] voodoo spell on
us dude
Oh what sorry is that a bad around of
your neck are you just happy to say on
darkest magic bro this is like you uh
you're playing Dungeons & Dragons and
you rolled a seven thousand but outside
of that she seems look she's a big smile
Hardy you know looks healthy looks like
she has healthy kind of neck um full
lips full lips has fake horns they look
except she doesn't get a lot of sleep
very similar to lizard they don't sleep
a ton yeah she has bags on bags around
her eyes
lizard bags dude that's actual luggage
bro I mean talk about luggage baby
somebody can make a beautiful pair of
boots out of this lady or a purse oh man
we're going to hell dude you know it's
crazy you know she's already there
that's her trick she shows up people say
mean things they go to hell BAM right
there and get some get by get to me bite
some but ya seem like a great aunt yeah
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]